una sera tutti sono safina ma sono un
attivista per i diritti umani tempo fa
mi facevo chiamare giornalista free
lance
semplicemente una ragazza un essere
umano come tutti voi quello che cercato
di fare negli anni e cercare di andare a
trovare problemi e cercare di risolverli
in qualche modo dalla persona che dorme
per strada al tossicodipendente alle
persone che arrivano con le imbarcazioni
sicilia vivo a catania sono laurea in
scienze politiche e lavora in tribunale
come mediatrice culturale
bene cosa vi devo raccontare in questi
quindici minuti
vi racconto quello che batte qui dentro
non è possibile studiare nei libri
possono essere i libri di storia possono
essere altri libri non è possibile
sapere che è un miliardo della
popolazione mondiale è analfabeta
non è possibile pensare che un miliardo
della popolazione mondiale non ha
accesso all'acqua pulita cioè quello che
semplicemente noi la mattina apriamo ci
facciamo una doccia magari che dura
un'ora e mezza o semplicemente
quell'acqua che apriamo per lavare una
strada non è possibile pensare
che due miliardi della popolazione
mondiale non hanno l'accesso
ai servizi sanitari a delle strutture
che possono in qualche modo
attenuare
nel solo nel 2005
che di tre milioni di persone sono morte
tra i ds vorrei ricordare a tutti voi
che
solo tre giorni in tre giorni le spese
militari nel mondo equivalgono a un anno
le spese
per la lotta alla riesce allora un fondo
di ipocrisia c'è questi sono dati che
non servono a nulla quello che serve
realmente fare qualcosa cosa si può fare
all'età di 14 anni ho iniziato a catania
ho iniziato ad accogliere le persone che
arrivano con le imbarcazioni tutti
coloro che arrivano in sicilia
passano dalle stazioni le strade sono di
chi ama le stazioni mi chiamo scendete
semplicemente nelle stazioni toccate le
persone che continuano i viaggi i loro
oggi il secondo viaggio della speranza
verso il nord europa perché l'italia
rimane un paese di passaggio toccare
queste persone guardarle negli occhi ci
rende molto più responsabile che rende
semplicemente un essere umano molto più
responsabile io quando esco di casa la
mattina riesco a vedere le mie mani
rosse semplicemente perché il sangue
al di là del mar mediterraneo
mi appartiene
appartiene a tutti noi cioè vedere
queste mani rosse la mattina e rivederle
così la sera è un obiettivo è un
obiettivo di tutti i giorni io ho fatto
iniziato con una mensa
ho preso una stanza da una caritas
inizialmente ho detto che dovevo fare
semplicemente devo semplicemente
cucinare con il tempo ho iniziato a
insegnare italiano ho iniziato a
prendere i nudi tutti gli avvocati
eccetera eccetera ho iniziato in qualche
modo io non amo l'assistenzialismo
ho sempre cercato in qualche modo di
dare degli strumenti e le persone che
arrivano qui in italia o altrove anche
su internet cercare in qualche modo di
tradurre delle informazioni rendere le
persone
partecipi del loro futuro semplicemente
in questa stanza sono riuscita insieme a
cinque ragazzi a cucinare circa 4 400
persone mentre qatariano a catania non
c'era un pranzo c'era solamente una
sorta di cena alle cinque e mezzo e alle
sette di sera e credo che ogni essere
umano prima di tutta la filosofia che si
può fare tutto quello che noi possiamo
dire credo che l'essere umano prima deve
avere questa piena per poi poter
ragionare per poi poter studiare per poi
poter fare politica e fare tutto quello
che tutti noi facciamo le foto che
vedete dietro che scorrono sono
l'accoglienza in questi ultimi due anni
sono le l'emergenza siriana e non solo
persone che mi hanno conosciuto dentro
la stazione di catania i primi primo
gruppo erano 50 persone con il tempo
hanno preso il mio numero di telefono e
hanno iniziato a scrivere il mio numero
di telefono su facebook su facebook la
primavera araba
è andata su facebook che è il mio numero
di telefono
stranamente quasi tutte le persone che
decidono di mettere piede su
un'imbarcazione
hanno il mio numero di telefono da qui
il mio lavoro si è trasformato in
qualcosa di diverso in qualcosa di molto
più molto più faticoso ma molto più
bello il fatto che una persona ti chiamo
da un'imbarcazione ti dice per favore
chiamo da guardia costiera di loro che
siamo 300 persone uscite da alessandra
in navigazione da dieci giorni
l'imbarcazione di legno c'è stato un
trasbordo in mare i bambini piangono una
donna sta per partorire le onde sono
alte sta piovendo comunica la guardia
costiera che ami la guardia costiera la
guardia tesserati risponde i primi mesi
quando non mi conoscevano dopo tre
chiamate la guardia costiera
mi hanno richiamato dicendomi su finaval
mi hanno dato anche l'indirizzo di casa
mia giusto per ricordarmelo lei è stata
denunciata per favoreggiamento
all'immigrazione clandestina
mi ricordo che quella serata mi andai al
primo posto di polizia incontrai la
digos fc questo arrestatemi sono stata
denunciata verbalmente della guardia
costiera dal comando generale di roma
lo stesso comando generale di roma ha
conosciuto a questa pazza questa folle e
adesso il comando generale di roma
qualsiasi orario 3 4 del mattino chiama
per mettermi in chiamate di gruppo con
delle imbarcazioni in difficoltà
cosa significa essere una chiamata di
gruppo con un'imbarcazione in difficoltà
non significa solo tradurre anche perché
se fosse solo tradurre la domanda che mi
faccio è vivo in italia da 26 anni non
ho mai capito perché il comando generale
di roma non ha un interprete
io potrei anche fare da interprete al
comando generale 24 ore su 24 senza uno
stipendio la domanda fondamentale perché
non avere un interpreta arabo
140mila persone che sono arrivate in
italia in quest'ultimo anno dalle
imbarcazioni hanno parlato in arabo
quando hanno parlato in inglese le
informazioni che hanno dato era un
informazioni basilari
a volte il problema fondamentale non è
solo la lingua e anche cerchi di qualche
cercare in qualche modo di gestire le
persone che stanno a bordo cioè gridare
urlare e dire basta non mi dare più
informazioni che non hanno un senso ad
esempio le donne gridano e bambini
piangono grazie sei in mare urlare e
dire coordinate e nata e coordinata e la
risposta dall'altra parte di successo
ora mentre ero nella stanza 9
un'imbarcazione ha chiamato adesso è
un'imbarcazione che uscito dalla libia
continuavano a dirmi non sappiamo
prendere le coordinate non sappiamo
usare il gps
perché non ce l'abbiamo non sappiamo
usare il gps che è dentro il telefono
thuraya semplicemente gli ho spiegato
come prendere le coordinate milia
comunicate e ho chiamato la guardia
costiera quello che facciamo dentro la
quel che faccio insieme ad una ragazza
di nome agata dentro la stazione di
catania tutte le foto che vedete
l'ambiente
c'è
questa è la un giardinetto vicino alla
stazione di catania
prima cosa fare dei biglietti biglietti
di treno sconto comitiva 68 euro tutti
partono felicemente verso milano da
milano cominciano il secondo viaggio
della speranza verso il nord europa
sfidando il protocollo di dublino
68 euro vi dico il prezzo perché dovrei
anche parlarvi dello scacchismo di terra
sconfiggere lo schiavismo di terra non
lo si sconfigge con gli arresti e non è
mai stato sconfitto con gli arresti a
catania
sono riuscita a bloccare lo scautismo di
terra e non me ne vanto perché tutto
quello che faccio non l'ho mai fatto
per dire che l'ho fatto semplicemente
l'ho fatto per sentirmi essere umano
semplicemente tornare a casa e avere una
coscienza pulita riuscire a dormire e
mangiare quel poco che di giorno riesco
a mangiare e sentire che realmente me lo
merito
ska fismo di terra persone ferme davanti
alla stazione davanti centri di prima
accoglienza a persone che ti dicono sale
sale sale in macchina dai dai dai che ti
portiamo noi a milano 500 euro 400 euro
non andare in stazione perché c'è la
polizia perché si identifica con le
impronte e non puoi continuare il tuo
viaggio verso nord europa perché c'è il
protocollo di dublino bene tutto questo
sconfitto quello che vedete le
fotografie dentro la stazione ogni
giorno partenze di 200 300 persone prima
cosa facciamo i biglietti seconda cosa
le schede le schede telefoniche sono
qualcosa di piccolo ma di
importantissimo per chi ha fatto una
traversata di dieci giorni sette giorni
due giorni senza che la propria famiglia
tanti ragazzi sono partiti senza dire ai
propri familiari che erano in viaggio
un ragazzo è arrivato a catania
dicendomi dammi il tuo telefono voglio
chiamare mia madre mia madre fa che sono
in libia e io gli ho chiesto ma non è
possibile
sei partito senza dire la tua famiglia
che a rimare mia risposta mi ha detto mi
vergogno delle lacrime di mia madre le
voglio sentire adesso lo devono essere
lacrime di gioia
la terza cosa che facciamo andare nelle
banche ma anche di catania semplicemente
far fare queste persone cambio da
dollari ed euro semplicemente indicando
a queste persone quello che bisogna fare
senza ricorrere a persone che per strada
magari possono dar loro dei soldi falsi
un'altra cosa importantissima dopo che
si fanno tutti i biglietti dopo che si
cerca in qualche modo di scherzare a
dividere
arriva il momento importante che è
quello delle informazioni raccolgo tutte
le persone dentro la stazione di catania
metto un megafono qui giro il microfono
dietro e il microfono avanti perché fa
sempre la sorta di interferenza qui cari
che sono dietro soffrono perché sentono
questa fase e quelli che stanno avanti
cercano in qualche modo di addio questa
città per dare informazioni ci sta per
dire che noi non possiamo continuare il
nostro viaggio verso nord europa si sta
per parlare del protocollo di dublino
bene
cerca in qualche modo di dar loro tutte
le informazioni e tra queste
informazioni anche guardate che partite
col treno villa villa san giovanni
milano state attenti da villa san
giovanni fino a napoli chiudetevi
prendete le cinture chiudete la porta
non per qualche cosa ma siccome sono qua
da 26 anni
so che qualcuno potrebbe aprire la porta
e so che potrebbero scomparire i soldi
che avete dopo di che cerca in qualche
modo di dare tutte le informazioni che
possono servire a queste persone che
siano persone che siano informazioni
legali o che siano informazioni in
qualche modo anche banali questa foto
questa è una delle foto che più amo
durante questi due anni non successe
tantissime cose dentro la stazione di
catania il ragazzo che vedete con questo
i due ragazzi con questi meloni con
questo melone spezzato in due e con i
numeri 25 ve la racconto stavano facendo
dei biglietti vedo che la sua data di
nascita e il primo agosto
io ho una filosofia del mare la
filosofia è la seguente le persone che
mettono piede su un'imbarcazione quando
scendono a terra sono nati per la
seconda volta è una nuova nascita una
nuova nascita semplicemente perché devi
ricominciare
devi imparare una lingua è sì serve
qualcuno che ti spieghi dove si trova il
panificio più vicino ti serve qualcuno
che ti spieghi che dentro la stazione
per poter andare in bagno devi spendere
un euro magari ha lanciato anche un
panino che costava 50 centesimi ma
questo non è un problema devi spendere
un euro
qui
questo ragazzo faceva il compleanno dal
primo agosto mi ricordo che quella
giornata durante l'accoglienza di circa
300 persone mi arrivarono in quella
giornata 7 ss in questo telefono 7 ssss
che il registro sempre perché persone
che mi hanno chiamata non sono mai
arrivate
tante di quelle persone che hanno
lanciato un sos non sono mai arrivate
persone a cui non ho mai fatto un
biglietto del treno persone che non
hanno mai preso il mio telefono persone
che non mi hanno mai detto dov'è il
bagno persone che non mi hanno mai
chiesto cos'è il protocollo di dublino
che cos'è la bossi fini questo ragazzo
cosa abbiamo fatto semplicemente ischia
o messi d'accordo insieme a dei ragazzi
che hanno viaggiato con lui e hanno
fatto la traversata con lui è bene ha
detto ma che sei possiamo farli prima
della partenza vabbè una torta costa 20
euro in tasca o 5 euro e no non si può
va bene ok decidiamo un melone non solo
dimenticherà mai
perché una torta è molto semplice il
melone no
2 euro due candele
finito il discorso
complice il mio amico tech dai e abbiamo
cominciato questo tanti auguri a te in
tre lingue arabo inglese e italiano
italiano ero la sola ma mi guardavano
che una pazza
ci sono piccole cose anche quando non ai
fondi anche quando non ti arrivano mille
euro al giorno anche quando ti arrivano
mille euro all'anno ci sono piccole cose
che possono cambiare la vita lo sguardo
le sensazioni delle persone
anche questo può cambiare tanto cioè tu
stai facendo accoglienza sei una spugna
io mi sento una spugna quando faccio
accoglienza perché mentre fa il
biglietto mentre cammini con una persona
verso il bagno mentre vai verso
l'ufficio della western union mentre
vipers e la banca sei una spugna è una
spugna anche senso cosa fanno spugna
cioè dell'acqua a terra metti questa
spugna questa spugna assorbe
assorbi l'uomo che si dice hanno
sgozzato i miei tre bambini davanti e
meo che hanno giustiziato mio figlio
hanno ucciso mia madre hanno stuprato
mia sorella
qui ti rendi conto che quei discorsi
della serie o mio dio ma qui c'è la
crisi economica non è non è che li
possiamo prendere tutti
la risposta ovvia la 86 per cento delle
persone che sono uscite almeno che hanno
lasciato la siria in questi anni sono
nei paesi limitrofi cioè libano
giordania turchia
cosa ha preso l'italia l'europa in
generale
quanti ne ha presi quanti ne ha accolti
bene
qualcuno è rimasto in fondo al mare
per la tanta speranza non per
disperazione quando mette il piede in
un'imbarcazione non lo fai mai perché
sei disperato lo fai perché la speranza
del tuo cuore è talmente grande che ti
spinge a fare uno dei passi più
pericolosi che possa è molto più
pericoloso salire a bordo di
un'imbarcazione
prendere questa decisione
e non ad esempio entrare dentro fans una
città assediata da circa due anni
bene un bambino ti guarda finiamo i
biglietti tu magari non hai i soldi per
comprare 50 kg di cioccolata per tutti i
bambini e fai semplicemente questo gesto
ora sia il fiato
lui ti guarda
lo dice continua a guardarti
ti rendi conto che forse non ha più
visto un palloncino da tre anni
glielo dai ti guarda e ti ringrazio in
un modo particolare un modo diverso da
come ringraziano tutti gli adulti e gli
adulti ringraziano grazie grazie grazie
abbiamo chiamato dal mare grasse piace
bambi che ringraziano in un modo
particolare i bambini si appendono quo
non abbracciano i bambini si appendono
qua quando marino si attende qui ben
tutta la stanchezza che ti sei portato
avanti per un anno per due anni qui che
te la senti la sera quando vai a dormire
scappa via
va via bene questo tipo di accoglienza
dei pro e dei contro
ovviamente lavori tra favoreggiamento
all'immigrazione clandestina
eh si la bossi fini o di il reato di
immigrazione clandestina non ci capisci
più niente io mi sono sempre fatta una
domanda tanta gente mi ha incontrata
nella stazione di catania mi ha detto ma
veramente quello che tu fai a tutto
legale la mia risposta è stata sempre
perché abbiamo arrestato iceman
macchiate hanno preso tanti generali
dopo la caduta del nazismo
perché era tutto legale
era tutto legale
l'umanità e la legalità
certe persone nella storia e riescono a
prendere degli ordini e portare avanti
questi ordini io credo che non esiste
ordine più grande di quello che ti dà il
cuore
cosa potete fare tutti voi tutto lei lei
cosa
milano milano 36 minuti da qui dalla
stazione di milano
se noi chiedessimo tutti i rifugiati che
passano da questa stazione di scrivere
un foglio in questo foglio di raccontare
la propria storia
io credo che tutti noi smetteremo di
comprare delle cose che non hanno alcun
senso come il prossimo iphone 6
tante persone non hanno bisogno di cibo
né di niente hanno semplicemente bisogno
di un abbraccio di una carezza un
bambino che è il 233 mi ricorda tanto
certe epoche che ho studiato nella
storia a proposito questo numero è molto
più dignitoso rispetto a un altro numero
tante volte rifugiati mi spuntano
arrivano in stazione con 233 io quando
vedo questo fratello per favore copriti
coop.it copriti perché non riesco a non
riesco a continuare la giornata di
accoglienza per rilanciare una cosa così
che è una provocazione io
ho notato che il pane costa più dei
farmaci e questo l'ho scoperto quando
dovevo scendere in siria c'era un
ospedale da campo che mi chiedeva
paracetamolo per i bambini
mi sono resa conto che cento pillole di
paracetamolo costavano 3 euro
siccome scadevano siccome scadevano dopo
sette mesi me li hanno venduti a un euro
no io non ci ho creduto
cento pillole di paracetamolo
un euro e non è impensabile che un
bambino possa morire perché ha una
febbre alta
semplicemente impensabile
questo tipo di accoglienza a un'altra
parte che è molto difficile ed è la
parte dei naufragi
quando c'è una frase o smetti di vivere
smetti di vivere nel vero senso della
parola io ho smesso di vivere il 2
agosto smesso di vivere il 24 agosto ho
smesso di vivere il 6 settembre ho
smesso di vivere la 11 10 del 2013 il 3
10 del 2013
i morti i morti
i familiari non credono mai che i loro
figli sono morti non esiste ad ora fino
a questo momento nella croce rossa
italiana né altro una lista delle
persone morte o i cadaveri quindi i
familiari che hanno gli attivisti per
avere informazioni
grazie a tutti